valérie qui est magnifique vous êtes
très très belle valérie merci d'être là
vous êtes frêche c'est vrai non je vous
jure que c'est vrai ça mais comme cette
sensation qu'on a quand on enlève le
petit papier sur le yaourt et on sent
que ses frais bah vous c'est pareil non
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai voyons
près qu'on enlève là l'eau liquide la
cayman le yaourt awel d'un jet l'image
ouais bah ouais ouais ouais ouais
valérie merci d'être là valérie êtes
célibataire depuis cinq ans ouais
comment ça se fait c'est comme ça non
mais alors vous est difficile c'est sur
cinq ans et ouais je ne sais pas je sais
quoi votre style à mon style c'est vous
[Rires]
et où je parle clair et vrai peu trop
près trouvait alors la beauté de la
personne devant moi ça c'est apollon
valérie pouvait expliquer pourquoi
bernard mouchès que ça me fait beaucoup
plus vous plaît chez cyril s'il vous
plaît laissez le meilleur cyril ans
merci à bernard montiel vous avez dit
que j'étais mode style il ya bernard
montiel ce [ __ ] qui a dit quoi et
honteux qu'elle aime le fric valley
risque quoi il répond s'il vous plaît
non parce que vous êtes vous êtes
parfait vous êtes l'homme parfait
talentueux mais les clichés par exemple
banal et brun ténébreux
ténébreux que toi tu arrives à te dire
quand tu me voie du déni c'est sûr je
suis pas parano alors ça c'est sûr ban
est en tout cas une magnifique merci je
suis très heureux que vous soyez avec
nous mais je suis heureux aussi d'être
là avec vous un merci mise en garde tous
les soirs et à merci est ce que je peux
donner un petit conseil d'hommes
célibataires enfin pas célibataire à
sophie à valérie qui est célibataire
oui c'est quand on est un homme comme ça
elle devrait mettre un peu de couleur
parce qu'une femme qui en noir comme ça
on se dit jean valait un peu triste un
peu dépressive à elles manquent de
gaieté alors je suis sûr qu est ce qu
elle sourit mais on ne suis pas d'accord
avec ça parce qu'un petit je vous montre
ça va vibrer l a pas besoin
moi je vous dis moi je trouve qu'elle
est d'une fraîcheur et on dirait dans le
sauriez on dirait la rosée du matin
non vous dirais la rose et du soir
[Rires]